to help keep a handle on the spread of
covet here in the valley immunize nevada
doubling down on vaccination efforts
as hector mejia reports it is partnering
with mgm resorts this weekend
to offer entertainment and prizes to
those who get the vaccine
all right we've talked about the nevada
cash prizes before how about
concert and sporting tickets or hotel
and flight packages that's exactly what
mgm resorts is offering
at a pop-up clinic they're sitting up
tomorrow here on the las vegas strip
specifically at park mgm and that's
because currently fewer than 55 percent
of nevadans 12 and older have started
the vaccination process
those who get the coronavirus vaccine
this saturday will be entered in the
raffle
and here's what mgm resorts is giving
away a vegas football
package which includes flights to las
vegas for a football weekend
plus a two-night stay in a fancy suite
at mandalay bay
a boxing package with flights boxing
tickets and a sweet hotel stay
maluma and bruno mars concert packages
also with hotel states
this is all in partnership with
immunized nevada
the pop-up clinic will also offer
testing and live entertainment
it's open to anyone ages 12 and up who
still has not received
their vaccine if it's going to help you
from the worst possible outcome you
should definitely do it in packages
incentives are good
and if there's the money to do it why
not honestly i think it's something that
could work
just because it's like it's vegas you
know people are out here to have a good
time so that would encourage you to go
get the vaccine yeah definitely i think
it would encourage me and i think it
would encourage a lot of people
all right if you're interested here's
the information you can find the pop-up
clinic this saturday from 10 a.m to 6
p.m
again it's at park mgm next to italy the
services are free for anyone ages 12 and
older
you can just walk in no idea proof of
insurance will be required
and it's also open to locals you can
park over at
new york new york and find parking there
parking for locals is free for a couple
of hours
reporting from the las vegas strip
hector mejia 8 news dan